let's go next to our caller from the 603
area code
603 could really go either way because i
think 603 is new hampshire
where you have you know live free or die
and you have all sorts of different
things who's calling today from 603
hello this is adam um
i haven't really been out too much but
there's been
way more fighting way more biden signs
than i thought there would be
in new hampshire you're saying yes
all right that's good yeah so
my question if i have a minute is um
i was wondering like
if we should expand our use of
government
because i think we mostly refer to
government as
a the federal government like
with with land and a flag but i would
argue
if libertarians want their way and they
want to reduce the power of the federal
government
if the government
if the government is the authority with
the most power if you reduce that power
there's i would argue that there would
be
you would give the government status to
a private company because then they
would have the most power
and you would just be governed by a
different
instead of sort of a public entity a
more private entity
okay beautiful i don't know that i 100
understand what you're saying but i
think you're getting to two important
things that that are
that are crucial one is a lot of these
libertarian
uh pipe dreams or wet dreams or whatever
you want to call these things okay
they really are just replacing
government
as a regulatory body with whichever
guy gets the most guns the fastest and
uses those guns to take control of
something and
i don't know that we're better off with
that sam cedar has some really great
calls with libertarians talking about
this
and then number two sometimes you'll
hear from these
small government libertarians that you
simply don't need
an apparatus so large as a federal
government or even a state government in
some cases
um the reality is that when you have
multi-billion dollar transnational
companies trillion dollar companies etc
um you only the power of
of sometimes multiple federal
governments
uh across the world only that power can
actually regulate corporations that
large and adam i'm going to let you go
because it sounds so loud where you are
but i really do appreciate the question
sorry all right no problem adam from new
hampshire
seeing the new hampshire biden signs
that's good
uh i i think pointing out the folly
of some libertarian arguments that's
also very good
uh if you're holding don't hang up
because we're taking a
really quick break and we're going right
back to the phones